كيف ستتعامل واشنطن وحلفائها الغربيون مع
توجه الصين الى تعزيز انفاق العسكري وهل
في التنافس على هذا الصعيد ما سيعجل ان
يحول دون انزلاق التوتر بين الجانبين الى
المواجهه
[موسيقى]
اواجه الكثير من التحديات الاقتصاديه في
قطاع الصحه والتعليم لكن الصين تختار ان
تقوم بزياده الانفاق على القطاع العسكري
اكثر من القطاعات الاجتماعيه والتنميه
الاقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
الصين ترى نفسها
موضعها تهديد من جيرانها وخاصه في ضوء
التوتر الموجود في بحر الصين الجنوبيه او
بحر جنوب الصين وترى نفسها بانها وهي تريد
ان تصبح دوله عالميه وقوه عالميه في منطقه
المحيط الهادئ والهندي
[موسيقى]
الصين تقدم اي
مساعدات عسكريه لاوكرانيا ولا لروسيا
فالصين دائما تقف على جانب الحوار والسلام
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده وحلفاء يواجهون
تحديات وهم منخرطون في حرب في
اوكرانيا وهم يدعمون اوكرانيا في صدى
عدائي روسيا الولايات المتحده ايضا تواجه
تهديدا من كوريا الشماليه بالتالي تعمل
الولايات المتحده مع كوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان من اجل مواجهه التحديات التي
تواجهها تلك البلدان ودعم حلفائها الصين
ليس لدي تواجه لا تواجه اي من هذه
التحديات
ايضا لدينا مجموعتان هنا مجموعه المتحده
واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه من جهه ولدينا
الصين وكوريا الشماليه من جهه اخرى اذا ما
استمرت هاتان المجموعه بزياده الحضور
العسكري والارفاق العسكري والتدريبات
العسكريه هذا قد يؤدي في سياق عالمي الى
زياده سباق التسلح وزعزعه الاستقرار في
منطقه المحيط الهندي والهادئ وقد يؤثر ذلك
على حركه التجاره في العالم